uh yeah david blackwell
um was the first tenured full professor
black contender full professor at uc
berkeley he was almost
the first black tenured professor uc
wide
so he was in the statistics department
he was hired in 1954.
he was almost hired in the math
department at uc berkeley in 1942
and in fact he was interviewed it was
recommended that he receive an offer the
faculty voted
to give him an offer um but to quote
david blackwell you could you could find
this interview yourself on youtube
just search for david blackwell berkeley
interview
after it was decided that he should get
the job
the chair went home and the chair of the
math department
went home and told his wife and it had
been a tradition up until that point
that
the chair would invite all the math
faculty to their home to have to for a
meal
and uh the chair's wife said uh i don't
want a [ __ ] in my house
so they actually ended up not giving him
the offer they give the offer to someone
else um
but but yeah he ended up getting an
offer later from the statistics
department
about 12 years later in 1954. and you
know he's a
kind of well celebrated famous
probabilist and statistician
yes i just moved to uc berkeley as a
faculty member here about a year and a
half ago
and uh prior to that i already had some
friends who were
professors in the uc system for example
todd coleman
he's currently at uc san diego that
though he's soon going to move to
stanford
i've known him since i was a sophomore
in college uh he and i were in the same
real analysis class
he was i think he was a grad student at
the time i was a sophomore um
and wilford gangbo he's a math professor
at ucla
um i've known him for maybe a couple
years
i met him at a carms conference carbs is
a conference organized by
professor bill massey at princeton so
anyway they um they're people i knew
and they knew that i was coming and when
i came they reached out to me and they
said hey jelani we're thinking of
starting
some kind of summer research program in
the mathematical sciences would you like
to join us
so really it's the two of them who came
up with the idea and then i
tacked on at the end
our hope is that we increase the number
of of
black students pursuing phds in the
mathematical sciences
so we'll see that's our goal
yeah so they'll be doing math you know
research in the mathematical sciences
mentored by
one of the three of us so if for those
students whose mentor is either todd or
wilfred they'll be
in los angeles doing work you know
working on the research
at the ucla campus on the ucla campus
and then for those that i'm mentoring
they'll come to berkeley at the end of
the summer
we're also gonna have like a unified
event where we're gonna be at the simons
institute
um thank you simons um so those
who are in la will will come up to to
berkeley and all of us will
will have time at simon's where people
will present
their research to each other they've
done over the summer and also have some
invited speakers talk to them
students who i advise will be working on
topics in theoretical computer science
which is which is my research area
each mentor does things a little
differently i can tell you for me
in the past when i've mentored
undergraduate research
i i usually will give the students
several different
um kind of broad topics and then
ask them which one sounds most appealing
to them and then
once they identify one that sounds
appealing i'll give them some more
refined details
and then if they want to change their
mind early on they can
in terms of eligibility any any
undergraduate who's studying at a us
institution regardless of gender or race
or anything else is eligible to apply
and applications should be received by
january 31st 2021 to receive full
consideration
if you want to apply the application
website is already up
just search for david blackwell google
for david blackwell's summer research
institute
and you'll find it'll be either the
first or second link
it's a ucla website it's math it's off
of math.ucla.edu
yeah so i mean regarding the
representation of black students in phd
programs in the mathematical sciences
there is some public data for example in
computer science there's the annual
cra talbee survey and then in
in math and the mathematical and
statistical sciences there's
the ams annual survey so if you look at
the most recent sort
of those two surveys for cra which is
the computer science one
they bring things down by category like
computer science computer engineering
and i forgot what the other one is but
if you look at computer science
and you look at you know the percentage
of u.s citizens
i don't know sorry that's not exactly so
it's look at
the percentage of phd recipients in the
latest survey that year
um who were black u.s citizens
so that's 0.9 percent um
so it's quite low and then if you look
at um
the ams one they they measure it a
little bit differently they don't look
at
what percent of all phd recipients were
black yo citizens
which would include you know then the
percentage the denominator would include
for you know foreign nationals as well
right not uh
non-us citizens but um they look at
if you just zoom in on the u.s citizens
what percentage of those
receiving phds were black and in the
latest survey it was like 2.9
a little under 3 so the numbers are not
that
that high and you know regarding
uh you know hoping that the program
might
help to increase those numbers um yeah i
mean
i just you know it's you just see it
kind of
empirically everywhere you know
anecdotally in your life right like
um you know i used to
when when we lived in boston when me and
my wife our family lived in boston you
know we used to go to
an egyptian coptic church and
there was this like abundance of well
first of all a lot of people who
attended our church
were college age you know grad school or
undergrad
and there was this over abundance of
people who were either in dental school
or were thinking of going to dental
school after undergrad
right and i mean that's just that's one
example but you know
i as a kid i never even thought of being
a dentist not there's anything wrong
with being a dentist but the idea just
wasn't in my head
but you know there's always this i guess
network influence
you know it could be church it could be
your your neighborhood it could be
other you know other things but just
whoever is surrounding you you see what
they're doing and somehow that gives you
the idea to
to pursue to at least look into doing a
similar thing
so our hope is by you know by seating
people
uh by seeing more black students who are
going into this it might inspire more
people to do it
and i mean i see another place to like
another example of a geographic seating
is you look at something like the the
ioi it's a high school competition
and you know you look at this data is
public you can look it up yourself
the organization that selects and trains
the
team that represents america every year
is called the usa computing olympiad
usaco
you look at their website and every
every summer they list
all the students who have made it to the
final training camp
you know and then once they're in the
camp they then go through additional
contests to figure out who's going to be
on the actual team because every country
can only pick four people to be on the
team
but you know you look at who's made it
to that camp over the last decade
all that information is on their website
um
you know i made a spreadsheet for each
one of the nice i
i wrote down their name what grade they
were in and
where they did their high school where
where what state their high school was
in
and you know there are approximately 120
distinct kids who made it to that camp
over the last decade some kids made it
multiple times that's why i say distinct
and of that roughly 120 60
went to high school in california and
from that 60
57 so almost all the californians are
from the bay area
and when you look at where in the bay
area they're from
they're almost entirely from the south
bay so san jose palo alto
around that area not that many from san
francisco or the or
oakland or berkeley etc so you know it's
you look at that and you say well is it
is it because
all the smart kids are in america or you
know
half the smart kids in america live
within a small radius of san jose
uh probably not right um it's just uh
just network influence right so those
kids have once they have the inertia and
you know enough kids know about it they
tell their friends and then they get
into it
and now there's a culture down there of
aiming for this camp
and there are also extracurricular
programs that these kids enroll in
um to train further right so um
i mean i think that's that's what i mean
when i say kind of network influence
just
people do what they s what's around them
for me personally the way i got into
computer science is somewhat accidental
i mean i
i got a nintendo entertainment system
for my fourth birthday
and i played a lot of games and you know
over the years as a little kid
i i later got you know a super nintendo
and a genesis and a sega cd and a neo
geo and a game boy game gear etc
i was playing games all the time um
and eventually i got a computer that was
probably you know
i was probably like nine or something or
ten and eventually i got the internet
okay at home and that was a big deal i
mean it was not easy because we only had
one phone line and this was in the days
of dial up
so i couldn't be online while you know
my mom or dad were using the phone
and and also there were no local dial-up
numbers for
prodigy or america online etc i had a
call long distance
to puerto rico i'm from the virgin
islands so i had to call long distance
to puerto rico that was the closest
access point for
any dial-up internet so you know back
then i think
long distance dial calling was like 10
cents a minute something like that so in
addition to paying the monthly
fee for to the isp we're also paying a
lot of money
per minute to be online but you know i
did it my parents allowed me
um and you know eventually
uh being online enough and playing games
eventually you know i realized that
there's something called html and that's
that's how you make websites um so i
bought a book
on html um from the mainland u.s and we
went on a trip there
and i just read it and then i used to
make websites to practice
um and then later uh let's see
in high school so i was 16 i got another
trip to the mainland us
and i bought books on cnc plus plus so
at some point after making enough
websites i guess i realized
well you can't use html to make programs
like these games i'm playing
were not coded up in html html is
working web pages so i figured out that
to make games you need to know a
programming language like c
so once i found that out and i bought
these books on cnc plus plus
i read them from cover to cover and i
would give myself
give myself programming exercises in
high school and also in 12th grade i had
a computer science teacher
who who taught us some basic as well
so i learned a little bit of basic from
that but i was already into cnc plus
plus just from my own
reading i remember after i got into mit
as a senior in high school i went to the
visit day
and i sat in on a linear algebra class
and um that day they happened to be
coming covering kramer's rule to compute
determinants of matrices
and i you know i didn't know about
determinants or creators rule but
i learned from that lecture and when i
went home i remember i gave it to myself
as an exercise to implement
determinate computation using cramer's
rule which turns out to not be very
efficient it's an exponential time
algorithm
um but i didn't i didn't know you know
better back then i didn't know about
efficient algorithms
so but that was that was a good
introduction anyway to recursion because
um graemer's role is a recursive thing
by the way i eventually did find out
about program
competitive programming when i got to
college i got to college and
you know mit attracts a lot of these
olympiad type
kids who did imo and iowa et cetera so i
found out from them
and a couple of my friends told me about
a website called topcoder when i was in
college
and i got really into top coder um it's
a competitive programming website
nowadays i think code forces is more
popular but back then it was top coder
but i remember there was a summer where
i was spending
more than eight hours a day just doing
practice algorithmic problems on online
judge websites
and the weekends my weekends were almost
entirely like practicing
um algorithmic problems online so for me
it was for me it was like a game
so if only i had known about this
algorithmic competitive programming game
back in high school i probably would
have gotten really into it but instead i
was playing other
games like ultima online and starcraft
and diablo
as a professor what i often see is
students who have high exposure coming
in and able to get into research and
advanced coursework early
right so um i've advised
multiple students in research
immediately during their freshman year
or immediately after their freshman year
i even once mentored
a high school student in research and we
wrote a pre-print together with
with my postdoc and he's someone who he
was on the ioi team for singapore
but you know what these students have in
common is early exposure
and there are a lot of kids who come to
college they want to do math they want
to do computer science but
they come to college not even knowing
what a proof is or not knowing how to
write a line of code which by the way is
fine i actually arrived at college not
knowing what a proof was
i first learned what a proof by
contradiction was my freshman year in
college
but you know that means that you know
you don't you don't get familiar with
with um you don't get the mathematical
maturity
you know required to pursue more
advanced
research in mathematical sciences until
later in your undergrad career
and you know by the time you're applying
to grad school
you know you're well by the time by the
time you have enough mathematical
maturity to to try to do research you
you know you're a senior right and then
you're applying to grad school
and then you don't have you don't have
the same cv
that someone with early exposure had so
someone with early exposure
they know what research is they know
what proofs are they show up in college
they're already looking for research
opportunities their freshman year
by the time they're a senior they have
publications out maybe right or at least
they've done more serious they've
written some serious survey
they have a good undergraduate thesis in
pure math or in something that's
mathematical
so i think because because the college
experience is time limited
right it's four years and really if
you're applying for grad school
during senior year then really it's only
three years it's really because
as soon as senior year starts once you
know at the end of the semester first
semester you're already applying to grad
school
so um i think more can be done in terms
of early exposure
um for example training kids for
things like the imo and ioi you know
half the kids that are trying to make
the ioi team shouldn't be coming from
the bay area that doesn't really make
any sense in fact
if you look at if you look at the again
i have i have the data i got it off the
website
um in the last decade something like 24
states out of 50
sent zero kids to the national training
camp for the ioi
um and states that are big and populous
like new york
you would expect new york to actually
send a large number no new york sent
five or less than five in the last
decade compared to california which sent
60.
um so and i mean it's not it's not so
it's not
it's not just about um
wealth or or you know or
other things i mean it's it's really
network influence right
there are plenty of there are plenty of
wealthy people in new york who can
afford to have their kids trained
well for this kind of thing uh but you
know you don't you just don't see them
coming out of new york
like you like be like you see them
coming out of california or virginia
virginia also does very well
and almost all the virginians who make
it to the camp come from one high school
so all but one
in the last decade in virginia something
like 13 or so out of 14
came from thomas jefferson high school
of science and technology
um so i mean yeah so going out into the
world
um giving talks to high school students
you know here in berkeley we have the
berkeley math circle
so i once gave a talk to them on an
algorithm for fast integer
multiplication
um but it doesn't have to you know or if
you want to do more than just to talk
you know that's that's a very
lightweight way to make to have
influence give a talk
right if you can do more of that make a
program make a summer camp
you know that tries to reach kids early
and get them exposed to what math is
really about
or what their computer computer science
or whatever it's really about
you